let's get something clear right off the
bat big hammy acting isn't necessarily a
bad thing
subtlety and realism have their place
but so do grand gestures wild screaming
and jumping up and down like a mad man
sometimes overblown acting blends in
perfectly with the zany nests of the
film and sometimes it works as a
brilliant juxtaposition to all the
serious stuff happening on screen these
are some of the greatest over-the-top
film performances of all time the final
frontier
if you're a fan of exaggerated acting it
doesn't get any better than Star Trek to
the Wrath of Khan on one side of the
aisle you've got William Shatner as
Admiral james t kirk and on the other
hand you have and speaking of Khan the
award for deliciously hammy acting goes
to Ricardo Montalban for playing the
genetically engineered ubermensch with
perfect pecs in a twinkle in his eye
Montalban is having a blast as Kirk's
arch enemy whether he's making death
threats are giving romantic speeches the
man literally hisses with hatred it's
even more fun in the scenes where he's
playing against Shatner with all their
exaggerated gestures it feels like an
unstoppable force meeting an immovable
object Oh Fred it's a true space opera
and Montalban knows exactly what he's
doing
boldly going where no Star Trek villain
has gone before say hello to my little
friend directed by Brian De Palma
Scarface is one of the greatest gangster
movies ever made and that's thanks to Al
Pacino's performance as Tony Montana
with an outrageous accent Pacino bullies
his way through every scene dripping
with venom as he drops epic lines
why don't you try sticking your head off
joy the more cocaine he snorts the
crazier his performance becomes and
Pacino was absolutely mesmerizing as he
staggers through a restaurant telling
the patrons of course is tour de force
moment comes in the film's climax as the
drug addled kingpin grabs a machine gun
and utters his most iconic line it's an
incredible scene big and bloody and
unbelievably bonkers just like Pacino's
performance game over man the first four
Alien films were all anchored by
Sigourney Weaver's lean mean and
fantastic turn as Ellen Ripley
but while Weaver plays a strong Spartan
hero Bill Paxton takes things in a
slightly more eccentric direction in the
second film aliens as private Hudson
Paxton plays the ultimate dude bro who
thinks he's the ultimate badass Hudson
has a big dumb grin a cocksure swagger
and he walks around like a John Wayne
wannabe if there was an Oscar for
obnoxiousness
Paxton would have picked up the prize
she's gonna be a stand-up fight sir or
another bug hunt but when there's
Animorph show up all that frat boy
bravado scurries away leaving a
wide-eyed hudson in permanent freakout
mode it's not a game to Hudson anymore
in fact hail to the king baby while
Bruce Campbell's performance as the
unfortunate ash Williams was pitch
perfect in the first two Evil Dead
movies army of Darkness lets the man go
absolutely wild there's nothing holding
him back here and Campbell is having the
time of his life dropping one-liners
that are losing with cheese all right
when he fights a witch in a watery pit
Campbell plays the part like a WWE star
and when skeletal arms start popping out
of a cemetery his little dance through
the graveyard is downright delightful
the greatest showcase of his unique
talents comes when he battles an army of
pint-sized ash monsters and sings London
Bridge is falling down
it's an incredibly bizarre sequence
think Jim Carrey meets the Three Stooges
it's wonderful Shockley fun and when it
comes to over-the-top performances well
hail to the king baby thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]